okay so the simple answer is probably no
huge thank you for checking out the
video I've been poor and I'll see you
next time
no so I think that most people probably
have a bit of a complicated relationship
with The Last of Us Part Two I was
someone who read the leaks when they
first came out and though I wasn't
suggesting we Old Yeller naughty dog I
was pretty disappointed with the way
things were going it almost put me off
playing but I gave the game a chance and
in the end I did end up liking it even
if I wish that the story hadn't have
started off with Abby doing a Tiger
Woods impression out of the first
episode's release I ended up returning
to it and after playing The Chariot has
been a key theme that stuck out to me
when playing now I think that most
people see the game as being a story
about how an eye for an eye mentality
leaves both people blind it definitely
does show that but I think there's the
often overlooked theme of forgiveness
but can we forgive Abby well that's what
I want to discuss in this video and I
also want to go over how I think they
should handle the character in the
second season ever since the show was
announced there's been the constant
conversation topic of whether they
should do what they do in the game and
that got me thinking of the best way to
use her character if you you agree or
disagree then the thumbs up and down
button are there for you and also make
sure you subscribe for videos like this
every day we're also selling a Last of
Us inspired t-shirt to help support the
channel so if you want some cool
Merchant to help us out then that will
be linked as the pinned comment now the
creators of the show are extremely lucky
because they know the kind of backlash
that they got from the game this
hindsight will allow them to understand
what people liked and what people didn't
and adjust the show accordingly to
counteract the inevitable backlash just
last week the face model for Abby said
she still gets an hate mail over it and
because of this I genuinely feel bad for
the person who gets cast as hair in the
show so how should the series bring her
in to avoid this well personally I think
that the game already gave us the answer
I think I speak for most people when I
say that playing as Abby allowed you to
see things from her point of view and
most people that hated her probably
start to see why she did what she did
The Last of Us is the only game I can
think of where you actually played as
both a quote-unquote hero and villain
and it's a framework that really allowed
you to see things from her perspective
so that is the key and I think the
second season should actually all be
about Abby in her story rather than
doing it the way that we saw things play
out in the game now before you turn off
the video let me explain why you see on
paper Abby is very much the hero of Her
Own Story frame from her point of view
she's the person getting revenge on her
father's killer who brutally murdered
him killed most of her Firefly family
and also destroyed Humanity's chance of
getting a vaccine had we not played his
jail in the first game then we would
very much be rooting for Abby from the
off because on paper Joel's one of the
biggest pieces of in the world after you
see a champ however we did play ASM so
we totally get why he did it and even
though there'll be people that don't
condone it we can at least see things
from his side because we saw his
perspective we at least understand even
if we don't agree and I want to see this
implied with Abby in season 2 as well I
think the best way to make audiences
root for Abby is to hide the gel reveal
from those that don't already know it
therefore newcomers don't have this bias
and don't want to see her fail because
they don't know I also think it would be
a massive gut punch for viewers to
follow Abby on her journey root for her
and in the last scene make us realize
that she was actually hunting Joel for
the entire season it would be a massive
ocean moment that would completely mess
with the audience's head who had no idea
what was coming those that had been
written for her the entire time would
suddenly have to question what side they
were on and then they could see Joel's
death play out basically making it the
Red Wedding of the series season 3 could
then share things from Ellie's side have
his death early on and then we could
follow her on her quest for revenge and
the eventual Arc that happens in the
game now went off on a tangent there but
it all kind of ties back to the key
question of whether we can forgive Abby
or not I think it's an important
question too and what the game is really
asking us is if someone killed the
person that we loved could we let it go
or would we let our quest for Revenge
consumer entire lives that's very much
what Ellie wrestles with and in the
third Act of the game she's presented
with a choice she can either let things
go and stay on the phone with Dina and
her child or go and get revenge on Abby
she chooses the ladder even after Dina
says that she'll leave her and she goes
off and does it Ellie simply can't let
go and because of this she loses out it
shows just how the need for vengeance
always takes over and gives you tunnel
vision and how you lose what's most
important to you it's always reminded me
of that saying if he seek revenge he
should dig two graves as you'll lose
that no matter what and that's the thing
that Ellie's entire rock is about
forgiveness now this is very much
married in her relationship with Joel as
well in the game early on we learn the
pair are no longer on speaking terms
because she found out the truth about
the fireflies aliens of kissing dinner
in the Tipsy bison and at this point the
bartender shouts some homophobic slurs
Jill stepped in and he punched him which
is when Ali started to see jaws the
protective father that she wants did
that night the parent ended up speaking
to each other and Ellie said that though
she can't forgive him she is gonna try
now this scene actually plays out at a
key point in the game and it happens
during the final battle between Ellie
and Abby the third act you play as early
as she hunts her down and finds she's
being captured by slavers along with her
sidekick Lev the muscle-bound woman she
once was is no more and she's a shadow
of her former self due to the
malnutrition and back-breaking labor
she's been subjected to Ali ends up
fighting her and even though this is the
final boss it's pretty one-sided you can
probably be Abby with one hand tie
behind your back and it's in this moment
that Ellie realizes what she's doing she
sees his cycle of violence that's gonna
repeat with Lev and it likely means that
she's gonna be hunted herself one day
now this Motif is also repeating Abby
and after the fight in the theater she
does have the opportunity to take Ellie
and Dina out however Lev begs him not to
so she stands down and then lets them
live she very much gave Sally even
though she spent the last couple of days
hunting her friends down now this is
very much reflected in Ellie at the end
and whether you think it works or not I
think that we're very much meant to be
put in the position where we too forgive
Abby Joe was the character that we all
became very attached to and playing the
first game without like Ellie I think a
lot of us have learned to let it go and
accept that The Last of Us Part 2 It is
Well The Last of Us Part Two I still see
people at this day dropping videos about
it and when face models are getting sent
hate meals still you start to think is
this worth becoming an [__] for after
the recent playthrough of The Last of Us
Part 2 I really start to see Abby in a
new light and Ellie along with her in
the end she ends up forgiving Abby and
it really made me realize that I
probably should too though I absolutely
hated seeing Joel getting killed in the
way that he did the world that the
Creator's belt was ripe for this kind of
thing to happen the people in this world
don't get to choose whether they live or
die and whether we admit it or not all
did a lot of bad things this was very
much his comeuppance and we have the
choice over whether to still hold the
grudge our red or be like Ali and except
that unfortunately that's what happened
but we won't let it destroy us too now
whether he forgive her or not is
something else entirely but I hope at
the very least that this video has given
you something you think about in regards
to the second game also I realize I'm
coming across a bit holier than now by
being like oh you can't forgive Abby
well I can but I think it elevated the
second game for me realizing that I was
very much going on the same Arc that
Ellie was fictional characters in our
attachments to them are weird as they
don't exist and yet when they're killed
off we very much feel like a real person
has died it's a weird sensation but it
shows just how well crafted that these
stories are anyway I hope this has given
you a deeper appreciation for the second
game and obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on it in the comments below we
are in a competition right now giving
away the 4K Rocky box set of three
subscribers on the 15 of March and all
you have to do to be when the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
video if you want something else to
watch then one of our last of us videos
is linked on screen right now and
hopefully I see you over there right
after this by the way thanks for singing
to the video I've been poor I'll see you
next time take care peace